[Music]
[Music]
waiting to be sure people can see me
al looks like confirmation
that's a high
oh i gotta get this trimmed up
are we feeling musical
i guess
it fills the time decently enough um
hope everybody's doing well
this evening
um
i'm doing all right myself i'm a little
buried in work but
what the hell else is new
it
ben
hi carowind pirates
rebecca miss mickey wool miss wicked
wolf
molly
homebody logan
bailey's summer
oh cappuccino
lots of folks in good to see you all
hi there james how's wales
ah
hello from the netherlands well welcome
gregory
um so yeah i don't really have um
do you have much of a plan for this one
oh
we have a super chat right off the bat
so this is your reminder super chats
will guarantee that i will read your
comment i do try and keep up with the
chat but i make no promises otherwise
and it will get you a heart from me
so thank you very much aussie
going through all of classic doctor who
watching season eight right now third
doctor is such a dandy he is i've still
got a lot of holes in my classic
doctor who but i am i am
filling those holes
at a
steady and intermittent pace
you know as much as i can handle at one
time eventually they'll all be
completely filled
i don't have the um
the patience
to go chronological
just through
classical doctor who am i my hat goes
off to anyone who does have the patience
to do that because i just don't
what's the dumbest culinary mistake you
ever made accidentally left the slow
cooker on overnight after i made short
ribs and didn't realize i
um
was pitching the liner
um
i think the dumbest
thing i ever did and this is pretty
minor i haven't had like any real
cooking catastrophes i think dumbest
thing i ever did which was a lesson that
i needed to learn which was that um i
had this recipe that was a
um relatively
spicy recipe
and i made a larger serving
than uh the recipe was built for
and i upped the amount of the
the chili the
uh hot pepper flakes uh in proportion or
at least i thought in proportion and it
was
swelteringly hot um much more so than
should have been the case
uh i see what you did there vera
i thought you might
um
i hate pumpkin spice i actually am
fairly indifferent to pumpkin spice
um you know what actually i i like
better than pumpkin spice coffee
certainly um i like the pumpkin donuts
that um dunkin donuts gets i like those
there's this little
freaking fruit fly
huh
little bugger
and until i get him this is gonna keep
yes
my fruit
[ __ ]
have you seen or heard of the animated
mortal kombat movies called mortal
kombat legends if not
i can say uh they're just great fun i
have heard of them i've not seen any of
them
um which is a fairly
standard for me
i once made the mistake of using way too
much baking soda and cookies yeah i feel
like in general baking is more primed
for for catastrophe than cooking is
um because cooking's an art baking's a
science
um you mess you mess that up and it's
just whoo
uh when i saw your thumbnail i
immediately started panting
maybe uh hydrate a little get some fresh
air
i actually did watch classic who in
chronological order from 2008 to 2009
and that was when not when not every
story was on dvd so it was a mix of dvd
videotape and daily motion
now that's a commitment
um
like my my brain just
i i don't think i could like aside from
the fact that i have way too much other
crap to do
to do it i i think i would have a very
hard time
pulling that one off
um are you watching the next season of
westworld uh me and my dad have decided
not to it hasn't started yet has it
um i keep forgetting um
that there was gonna be another season
it didn't start did it
excuse me i'm checking that now
um i don't
know
i mean i might
um give it a shot out of
mostly
morbid curiosity just to
see if they actually know where they're
going with this no it hasn't started yet
okay
all right
um
because the the third season wasn't
gray
[Music]
first season was good second season was
awesome third season was
[Music]
and
um for a fourth season like most of the
characters i really liked are are um
either literally dead or effectively
dead there isn't a lot for me to latch
on to at this point so i don't know
we'll we'll see
thoughts on shang chi yay or nay also no
spoilers well my full review was up in
the break room brief thoughts are yay if
you are going to make me give you a if
you're going to force me into a binary
which i don't care for
i'll give it a yay
uh really glad you liked kenda i know
it'll be a while before you can get to
it but the description of snake dance
intrigue you yes i next time i get to a
fifth doctor i will probably have it be
snake dance
um i don't know when that'll be i need
to oh
oh i need to run another i need to
figure out what doctor i'm gonna do next
and i need to run another poll on the
patreon to figure out what classic one
i'm gonna do next
my thoughts on oliver and company
uh
good songs
but um it's
okay
kind of unremarkable honestly
but uh the
music's pretty good
why should i worry
why should i care
certainly not
not bad
you know there's i i would have no
reason to
um worn people off from it
it just you know it didn't do all that
much uh for me
i only saw oliver in company
once uh at most and i don't remember it
other than why should i worry
see what i remembered most as a kid
um
was the chihuahua
voiced by cheech marin
like the the poodle beat him up and he's
stumbling out of the room oh i think she
likes me man oh
i remembered him for a long time
i've seen the newest owl house episodes
yet no because i watch it
on disney plus so did they upload
the next five
because they've been doing them in
batches of five
i've so i've seen the first 10 episodes
let me see what we got here owl house
what's going on
[Music]
we currently have
available nope still still just 10. i've
still only got 10 episodes available to
me
um
on
disney plus so that's all i've seen
uh the chihuahua's name is tito of
course it is
uh the reason i'm excited for
uh shang qi see i need to work on that
pronunciation i think seeing it i still
say shang but shang
for shang chi uh
um
is when was the last time we got a big
budget martial arts film marvel budget
at that it's
it's been a while i feel like the last
attempt at it was
what was it 13 assassins or something it
was a keanu reeves movie it didn't do
well
um i suppose it's arguable
whether or not um
john wick is martial arts it's martial
arts informed certainly but it's as much
about gun play
as it is about hand-to-hand combat
do you think that tv is dying
it depends on whether or not you make a
distinction between television and
streaming i don't
really so for my money no no it's not
sorry
uh what new films are you looking
forward to this autumn i keep forgetting
what's coming out
um
i like i
i'm trying to now get over the habit
that i built of basically any time um
uh
you know i i saw a movie's release date
it was like yeah right that'll hold um
so i need to what is even coming out
the rest of this year
uh
2021
in film
let's take a look
what's coming out
all right
where are we we are into september
all right let's see
that was july here we go september
coming up we have
see if there's anything that even rings
a bell here
don't know it don't know it don't know
it don't care
don't care don't know it um
no no
no
no
this
okay well there's one i recognize dear
evan hansen but i don't care
and my little pony a new generation why
okay so
september's uh
a wash oh so they move venom to the
start of october so that's one how is
there another one
you mother
uh so there's that um
no
no
seriously
oh god
um oh no time to die finally comes out
i'm not looking forward to it but i'll
probably watch it anyways
um
because it like
theoretically if the pattern of daniel
craig bond movies holds it'll be good
because every other one's been good
um
because you know uh
casino royale was pretty good overrated
but still pretty good uh quantum masalas
was crap skyfall was great spectre was
garbage so hopefully no time to die will
be good
we'll see
um
oh the last duel actually looked
interesting to me
uh that's a ridley scott movie
maybe if that comes local dune well i'm
definitely gonna have to catch dune
because that ah that actually got
um
commissioned as part of a package so
yeah i've gotta get to that one
um
let's see
uh eternals that's a november
um
oh i forgot they've got the tick tick
boom adaptation i don't i might watch
that i'm not
like super stoked
for it
um oh ghostbusters after life is in
december all right so there's a there's
a few things there's a couple of things
um
and kanto i still don't really know what
that is yet
um
i have no interest in west side story
spider-man no way home that's that's
december the matrix resurrection
resurrection
the matrix resurrections um
which
i know there was like teaser stuff um
that was put out
uh i guess there was like a website or
something i don't know i didn't look
into it i'm waiting for a trailer i
don't have i don't have the patience
for
for viral marketing ooh play this game
kind of i don't have patience for that
nonsense anymore
uh the king's man i might give a shot to
um i really didn't like the second
kingsman movie you mother
oh
um
but you know hopefully this one can be
good
oh they're doing another version of
cyrano look i love cyrano de bergerac
but like stop
just just let it be the play
there's nothing good to be milked out of
a film version of that anymore ah
so i guess there's a handful of things
probably will take my time to see no
time to die he also didn't like spectre
spectre was ah
god
matrix re worcestershire
yeah sounds about right no args no i
never liked args
even like when when i was in the
demographic for the damn things i always
kind of thought that was like he
can you just
ah
can you not can you just give me
a a standard trailer
you're going to see the new dear evan
hansen movie not unless somebody pays me
no interest so far i'm not really having
a good time with marvel's what if uh
something's off i just can't put my
finger on i keep watching out of some
kind of loyalty
uh what are arg's uh altered reality
games
there it's it's a term that i don't even
know if how much it's still in use
it's a marketing
thing
not seen all the bond movies but from
what i've heard whenever bun gets a
permanent love interest it all ends the
same way she dies
well
i think he's only ever gotten what was
like internally meant to be a permanent
one once
i mean twice if you want to count casino
royale i wouldn't
but i guess some would
um
owl house is currently on hiatus what'd
you think of hunting talisman through
yesterday's life i i've
liked what i've been seeing i didn't
have enough new thoughts to like do a
video on just the five new episodes so
i'm waiting for the
like to see the whole rest of the season
to talk about as a whole
um
yay finally made a stream again oh nice
to see you here breathing nerd dumb
uh i've been working so much and my
bosses are extremely annoying when i
take a day off for the first time in 10
days they don't even know i'm quitting
suckers
you saw in the heights i did see in the
heights but i actually was curious about
in the heights i have no curiosity for
dear evan hansen i
don't care
like you're making an assumption that
like i i'm interested in any
musical
like i don't uh
i don't
care
about
a lot of them i if if the plot isn't
something that i'd be inherently
interested in
um it's very unlikely i'll ever watch it
i don't care about dear evan hansen i
don't care about west side story
musical is not a genre musical is a
style but it's not a genre any more than
anime is a genre it is a type of
presentation but the specific genre is
going to determine
whether or not i actually have any
interest in seeing the dang thing
did you like in the heights yeah i liked
it pretty well i didn't love it but it
was pretty good
um
there's a cool uh arg game that opened
in london real life mario kart where the
track and power lines are projected onto
a room service and you race each other
and use power ups and boosters
oh david waring thank you very much for
the support
that'll get you a heart right there
thank you for taking up the membership
uh don't watch what you don't care about
i try not to
as a general rule i try to avoid
obligation views
um
i still do it sometimes but i in general
i try to avoid that
i once saw a guy wear a shirt that said
buenos tardis
and it had the tardis wear sombrero and
mustache
[Laughter]
that's really dumb
that is really dumb but it also kind of
tickles me oh aussie nerd
thank you very much
for um
for picking up the youtube membership i
appreciate that
uh something i did recently is rewatch
the dc animated films that started with
flashpoint paradox
and i've never understood the hate for
damien wayne
i guess i've never understood anyone who
didn't have hate for damien wayne
i just
i find him absolutely insufferable
he's just this
he's just a little [ __ ]
and he doesn't get better
that's that's my main thing like in
theory for a character like that to work
he needs to have an arc he doesn't
really get better
over the course of these things he stays
a
quick to violence
just annoying thinks he's better than
everybody a little [ __ ]
he's irritating i don't like him
i tend to now think of him in the exact
terms that cell specs always described
him which is [ __ ] baghdamian
that's who he is to me
i thought on buffy the vampire slayer
spin-off uh
announced
willow witch's daughter becoming new
slayer
okay is that a thing or are you messing
with me
that doesn't sound like a thing
was damian wayne the robin from harley
quinn yes and one of the first few times
he worked because he
they were allowed to just acknowledge
that he was a snotty brat
yeah so that worked decently
i mean granted
part of the issue with
damien is that he
took up the mantle on the heels of tim
drake who is the best robin so you know
all right let's see
yeah now um i am calling it you uh you
made that one up there bailey
nice try
ah
started watching shameless because
friends recommended it and i'm so hooked
even if the family's a mess
i'm reluctant to try that one um
i i don't know something about it just
makes just reminds me of all the
sort of messed up family dramas from
premium
cable shows that i either didn't like as
much as everybody else or like burned
out on fairly quickly
get back here you son of a [ __ ]
um
i can remember trying to watch big love
i think it had two seasons of that and
i kept waiting for it to get good it
didn't
it just didn't now granted like that was
a while ago but still and even six feet
under which i did finish and was good at
times it put me through the ringer
um what about house of gucci will you
watch it i
i probably won't remember to because i'd
forgotten it was a thing until you
mentioned it so
i'm not particularly adverse to watching
it but i clearly it has not stuck in my
head so
oh hey meg
good just
excuse me
good to see you
i've been re-watching the new doctor who
series from 2005 to now this is the
third time first time i saw 10 and i
loved him second time i found him
overrated third time i fell in love with
him again ah that's that's how they get
you
i think one of the things aryan
characters need aside from an arc is to
be put on the back foot or put with the
character with a good dynamic i mean
like that's the thing
damien's dynamic with everybody is
basically just being a [ __ ] at them
that's just how he is with
everybody
and it's freaking boring
and annoying
and i don't understand why he like
granted this is based off the
ha
ha [ __ ]
uh this is based off the animated films
not the comics i haven't read him in the
comics but like in the animated films i
legit wonder why is he being allowed to
keep the mantle of robin
not only does he not listen he's
freaking dangerous
oh
i remem i forget what one it was
i forget
which movie it was but
um
there was one where
the job he was given in like this crisis
situation
where a bunch of people were there the
job he was given was to direct
civilians away from the danger
and he did that with explosives
i hate that kid
best thing that ever happened was when
was when nightwing kicked his ass
uh my two cents on damien he was raised
exclusively by the al ghul so of course
he would be quick to violence and and
quote batman he didn't have friends he
had instructors also jason todd okay
two things about that i will go back to
what i always say about characters i
dislike or people like oh but he's like
that because it's not that i don't get
why the characters like that
justifying something in the narrative
doesn't mean i'm suddenly gonna start
liking something i don't like i don't
like him as a character because i don't
like having him around not because i
don't understand why he is that way i
get why he's that way it just does
nothing to counteract and endear me to a
character who i do not like having
around and i also don't like jason todd
either but jason todd wasn't shoved into
freaking half a dozen animated films
that i might have otherwise found
something to enjoy about so i don't have
an extra grind on jason todd the way
that i do on damien but i also don't
like jason todd and i don't like that
they brought him back he was only
interesting when he was dead i will die
on that hill
red hood's boring there you go
there is there is uh there's your token
rant
[Laughter]
there will be others i have
little doubt have i seen the 2020
version of mulan
nope and i probably won't unless
somebody pays me
um at this point like i'm so
uh far out
from you know
being in the zeitgeist trying to talk
about it that like there's it's not
worth it to me
how about the arkham knight i didn't
play that
so
i know that didn't sound interesting
either from what i saw
the explosive was in the third film he
was in when he was in the teen titans
yes your reviews are burned into my
memory make of that what you will
oh i really did hate him uh
don't watch mulan it's not worth it well
like i said somebody would have to pay
me and then it would be worth it because
i already have disney plus so i'm not
even paying to watch i wouldn't even be
paying extra money to get it i just
would pocket the commission money and
through it and rant about it for about
20 minutes and call it a day
a musical film coming out soon is the
movie of everyone's talking about jamie
which is exciting i have not heard of
that at all
the film has richard e grant as a drag
queen and the west end musical was
brilliant
not familiar with that one
in the slightest
kid characters who are literally written
just to be
little [ __ ] who insult characters
piss me off it feels so lazy and generic
why make a kid uh
complex when they can just wisecrack
well i also feel like part of the reason
they make characters like that
into kids
is that if if a character was an adult
and behave like that
nobody would put up with him absolutely
nobody they would deck him
but because he's a kid
you can't just smack him upside the head
and say get over yourself you little
crap
no no he's a kid yeah well he's a shitty
kid so
yeah
have you seen the mini series the bite
i have not even heard of it so new
does it bother you that multiverse seems
uh to happen because of a mistake in new
spider-man trailer
um
no because that
is just
right now we've got three different
things setting off the multiverse so
no it doesn't really bother me
because we had
the
death of
what i think of as kang prime in loki
that appeared to set off a multiverse
we've got what if which implies a
multiverse already existing because you
have the watchers seeing all these
different versions and able to interact
with them but doesn't so far at least
and so now we've got um spiderman no way
home which appears to have multiverse
created by accident so no it doesn't
bother me because it's not the
definitive cause of the multiverse it is
one more thing that's going to result in
some multiverses what they seem to be
setting up um is the idea that um
there are
multiple things that can result in
the splitting of the timeline of the
universe and result in a multiverse and
i'm kind of okay with that
um all kids are creepy or few
infuriating there's no in between uh not
true my kid is neither of those things
all other kids are though i'll give you
that
have you seen cobra kai i have reviews
up in the break room of geeks of the
first three seasons
um i did not like the third season very
much at all i don't know if i'll watch
the fourth one
we'll see
um and it's okay
it's okay about the caps
be doing a live stream on twitch
tomorrow yes uh usual time 10 30.
what do you think of bo burnham i like
him i've seen a lot of um
very well thought out criticism of him
sort of coming from a place of
um
white privilege which i think he would
be the first to acknowledge his own
limitations in that that doesn't make
those limitations suddenly vanish so i
don't think he's in um
impeachable
in that way
um
but
um i enjoy his work and i have for a
while
uh
let's see here
i'm glad you discovered infinity train
here's hoping the rumors of our
continuation are true
are you going have you gotten around to
the episodes of the hour house you're
waiting on your kids to see i have i
don't plan to do a video devoted
specifically to them though because
i just i i've got too much on my plate
to to dedicate a
review to every five episodes that
become available on
um
disney plus so i'm waiting for it all to
be there and i'll just do an over an
overall review
my favorite dc animated films is
all-star superman and superman versus
the elite
if it's not apparent i love superman
what's a dc animated film you don't hate
well first of all both those are good
their death of superman was shockingly
good
um
the reign of the superman was terrible
but okay ones that are good
uh
the death of superman
was good crisis on two earths was good
gods and monsters is very good um i
liked the constantine animated film that
they that they had i liked the assault
on arkham quite a bit um
there are some that i enjoy
but i hesitate to call super good like i
enjoyed batman bad blood
um but that was almost kind of in spite
of itself
um but i did enjoy that one
um in general i find the original ones
usually better
um than the ones
adapting direct stories although like
there are exceptions
have you seen dug days on disney plus i
have not
i
will try but like i don't know when
we watch shira lately i would love to
don't have the time
i'd like
i i i don't think folks realize like how
much
crap i try and get
done in a day between
prepping for video shooting videos
editing videos editing podcasts
trying to get um
the last of the
rewards for the kickstarter
mailed out um
once i get some of that stuff fully done
i need to
get into editing the audiobook like i i
don't
i don't really have uh
much in the way of relaxed time in my
day unless i force it which i'm trying
to do
more but i keep telling myself that you
know
well catch up on some stuff first and
then you'll be able to relax of course i
never i never
do
what's your favorite example of them in
media of a location that acts as a
villain
example silent hill ooh
that
that is an interesting question
that i do not think i'm going to be able
to wrap my head around live on
camera
um
like i i'm sure i could come up with
examples if i if i sat down to think
about it i am drawing a blank right now
but yeah
why don't you like catherine apart from
six i don't dislike her i just find i
just find her slightly boring compared
to a lot of the others
lucy would if she could i love the name
you get a heart thank you so much will
you ever do a ranking of the sonic
screwdrivers um i might um that's one of
those things that has been sitting
um kind of on the back burner as like an
idea to do eventually um
so yeah at some point maybe
um
but i i could i couldn't tell you when
uh could you tell
us your thoughts on loose and amity's
progression then well as far as i've
gotten i thought it i think it's been
going very well like especially if you
remember the pace at which things went
in the first season the the crush was
steadily built up on amity's side and
then second season starts the crush
starts getting built up more on lucy's
side and then they
they
start
they actually ask each other out i like
i think it i think it's worked well i
think it's been paced well
um now that the holiday season is near
any favorite christmas episodes of shows
i am particularly partial um
to
uh
garfield
christmas i like that one a lot
um i know it's not a
christmas episode of a show but like the
animated version of how the grinch stole
christmas
that's hard to go wrong
um
i'll watch charlie brown christmas um
i'm not as attached to it as a lot of
people my age are
um trying to think
what else there are probably others that
i'm drawing a blank on
uh what are your thoughts on paranorman
it's great
i think it's like his best film
uh
let's see
it's not the holidays without a garfield
christmas oh yeah it's good stuff
you gotta love
john's grandma who does a hundred
sit-ups every morning calls him
soft what's your favorite doctor who
episode that everyone else seems to hate
mine's the crimson horror
i mean it's probably can you hear me
um which
i
i say that but like i honestly
don't know
whether that gets hate because of the
episode in specific or if it's by
association because it's in series 12
and there's a whole chunk of people who
just hate absolutely
absolutely everything that
um chipnell whitaker are involved in so
like i don't know if that episode will
eventually get a reassessment i really
like it though
do you have amazon prime video i do
have you played any resident evil i
played two and seven uh check out the
new mini series on netflix for some
reason as well i have
played
an hour of resident evil 4
about
15 years ago
yeah that's
that's all i've got
i want to get into big finish but i'm
not sure if the content was worth the
price uh do you think you get your
money's worth out of out of the
continental tent well brandon to get a
sense of whether or not you think it's
worth money check out big finish on
spotify they've got the first 50 of the
main range up there for free
so
give it a listen and figure out if you
think what they do is worth your money
oh aussie nerd
i thank you another hut for you doing a
podcast on doctor who with a friend of
mine and i'm working on a watch list for
classic who and a listen list of big
finish i i feel like if you're going to
put together a watch list or a listen
list it has to be
um
it has to be
for a specific purpose like
a watch list of
the best dalek stuff or a watch list of
the best stuff for this doctor a watch
list of the best um
you know ones well i'll plug my own
video coming out on saturday i'll watch
this of the best political uh
politically minded episodes or things
like that because if you're just like
trying to come up with a watch list of
the whole thing that's that's
kind of a lot
i like oxygen not gonna lie i think lots
of people hate that do they
that's news to me i love oxygen oxygen's
great
i haven't done 100 sit-ups in my entire
life probably
i've done that many collectively i'm
pretty sure
recently rewatched your take on
everybody lives moment uh from the empty
child i think
uh it's a lot about the fact that it's
the war going on but i like your take
too
not valid
that that that is that is valid that's
an element um
what do you think of the scene where
loose and anemone ask each other out
would you think of hunter bellows right
for goodness sake okay you're just
throwing everything at me i thought that
scene was adorable
i don't really have a thought on hunter
bellows is okay
like i'm waiting to learn more
rain was fine
king's dad hasn't really done anything
yet other than exist so
and that yeah out of the episodes i've
seen
i lost track of doctor who when i cut my
cable just after capaldi came in but i
picked it up again on streaming just
finished season 8. well i hope you enjoy
it jon
i miss one doctor who was free on amazon
prime
i miss when it was on netflix
yeah keeps moving
thoughts on lilo and stitch um
it's fine
i think it's very overrated by
my generation and their abouts my
generation is slightly younger
um
i think they should put some more recent
big finish on spotify their early stuff
is good but it's not completely
reflective of the things they do now i
mean that's fair but it'll give you a
taste of the medium and at least give
you a sense of whether or not you're
going to be able to get into this format
so
um
i think it's fine
i still think vera should dress up as
the
should dress up the new puppy as king if
i could figure out how to do that my kid
would lose her mind
[Laughter]
power rangers has announced their new
green ranger is their first lgbtq ranger
and first
female one
they've had female power rangers before
like but
i'm very confused by that
like i don't watch power rangers i was
too old for it when it first came out
but
i remember there were females
off topic but i really love the
partially tied blue hair i'll be meaning
to go for something similar for some
time but never get around to it well
part of the thing is like that there are
parts that are just
flat out not dyed but
the reason it's
it's like the color doesn't start until
down here
is not by intent it's because that's how
much my hair has grown out since the
last time i had it professionally dyed
and at this point i'm just doing color
refreshes on the parts that have been
bleached at some point and i do that at
home
so
you'll know when i have gone to get a
professional
um die again because you know it'll
it'll be he'll be further up
what are you dressing up as this year
for halloween i have
no idea
i oh god i have to come up with
burlesque stuff though cause i've got
i've got a show that i have to do two
numbers for
on the 15th of october and then i'm
hosting a show on the 16th of october
so i gotta get on that
oh
wording this carefully haven't been
familiar with the director's previous
work
uh it was predictable that a certain mcu
actress was going to appear in chongqi
okay
i just i'll take your word for that i
don't
what else did that director do
um
[Music]
do do do
i
[Music]
don't know that director's work at all
so
okay
dress up as king george iii from
hamilton i can neither afford the crown
nor the furlined cape
what's your favorite torchwood episode
i don't know because the only piece of
torch would i really like is um children
of earth and i can't really pick a
favorite out of that miniseries
let's see
movie made
90 million over the weekend yeah shang
chi is doing really good which i'm glad
for
i mean not so much that like
oh thank god people are going to the
movies like honestly maybe people
shouldn't be going to the movies
said the person who um you know went to
the movies to see it in my defense
during a matinee there were only two
other people in the theater but
i'm glad it's doing well so that
a poor performance cannot be used as an
excuse to not
um
put
uh more diverse people or asian
characters specifically front and center
so
do you love it when i troll you actually
i don't
nothing in the discord but plug it
anyway i think somebody actually put
something before i put the alert up let
me check that
reminder though um
there is um
there is a council of geeks discord
which is a patreon exclusive perk
and there is a channel dedicated to the
live streams where people can ask
questions
um and they are guaranteed to be
addressed much like super chats are in
here
there is one question it was asked
before i put up the notice so
are you aware that peter capaldi is
playing
or played past tense a trans character
called vera
in a series uh of prime suspect uk
detective drama with helen mirren
this was in the early to mid 90s
no i did not no wait seriously
hang on hang on
sorry i've i've been told um too much
stuff this evening that i'm like uh
no
so um
forgive me while i
not trying to be too incredulous
see 90s that's 2000 90s
here we go
[Music]
92
[Music]
92 93
oh yeah oh god he did
prime suspect three from 1993
played vera reynolds
what is that streaming on anything
prime suspect
streaming is it streaming
oh it's on amazon prime
i have it
oh
i
i might need to check that out
i like part of me is nervous though i'm
afraid i'm going to watch it and then be
disappointed by the by the depiction
because you know i kind of the bar got
set for me um sean bean in tracy's story
on um
the accused so
i haven't had my haircut since march
2020
yeah that's
that's fair
having re-watched the original dune
uh only now realized that sean young uh
was in 280 sci-fi films
ruined by unnecessary narration
[Laughter]
yes
that is accurate
when does the doctor who when does
doctor who airs newest season
i have no idea
because they haven't announced it
uh
oh goodnight meg
i'm glad you stopped in
hope you're doing well
same bat time same bat channel yes
indeed
on a scale of one to ten how sexy do you
think you are not really for me to say
because
i'm not the one trying to get with me
that's kind of up to other people isn't
it
yes no i have seen shanghai have a
review up in the break room of geeks
where's my pumpkin spice oh jesse you
basic white girl
good to see you jesse glad you could
stop in
uh
the pumpkin spice must flow ha ha
[Music]
uh do you know that matt smith plays
hunger in morbius
i understand those words in isolation i
don't know what they mean put together
and the most basic of white girls i'm
proud of it yeah own it
go ahead and own it
uh
dune the dessert planet
i've never had pumpkin spice but i've
smelted any candle here's the best
iteration of pumpkin flavored anything
that i've ever had
um my kid's mother
i don't know if she's made them in a
while but she used to make these
pumpkin chocolate chip cookies in the
fall
those were really good
they were huge too they were like this
big around
oh that was good stuff
do you think marvel should introduce a
transgender character how is there
another fruit fly
oh you bastard
um
i would like them to
um i don't have like a suggestion for
the
uh
the best way to do that
um
or what character to do that with as
there aren't a lot of transgender
characters of notes within the marvel
comics
um
but i mean i'd like to see it
[Music]
i had pumpkin pie sour beer the other
day and it was like drinking a liquid
pumpkin pie i was so happy
you can keep that one jesse
you know what's crazy
uh
there's not a lot of uh rock sea
shanties and that's unacceptable
you haven't been looking in the right
place
my friend
there is a pirate themed metal band
do yourself a favor
look up ale storm
in particular look up the song that they
wrote uh about an anchor
that
do not listen to it on the job
nsfw
[Music]
how many flies do there have to be
before you know it's an invasion any
amount is an invasion and i will treat
it as such i will exterminate every last
one of them
that glass pipe you used to smoke with
do you still have it nope
no i do not
hailstorm is amazing thank you molly see
molly knows what's up
i think after 2020 no one's making fun
of pumpkin spice anymore because if
that's what gives you comfort that's
fine we all need a little comfort yeah
yeah that's fair
uh hey jeffrey nice to see you stop in
uh tom waits rain dog sounds rather
piratey
while i mean tom white's always sounds
drunk so
you know
he he can go piratey
seeing the recent tv spots for the new
one the uh oh for the new dune this
baron hart conan has actual menace this
time well yeah so hopefully it works
um
how do we know
that this plan would oh god sake never
mind i'm not reading that out
the ingredients of pumpkin spice are a
protection spell
yeah that tracks
how much you looking forward to the
eternals i'm still i'm more curious than
hyped for the eternals and no i have not
seen nomad land i don't really have a
lot of interest it's just not my kind of
movie
uh tom waits makes a great devil in the
imaginarium of dr parnassus i wish tom
waits did more acting
honestly um
because he's he's been good in
everything i've ever seen him and he's
just not in very much uh as an actor
uh
no mad land same directors the eternals
i know
i know and i'm sure marvel was
thrilled when um
when that direct when that um when that
one oscars and they could say they had
an academy award-winning director um
working on the eternals
who's your least favorite character from
from hamilton
and peggy
i don't really care five minute warning
yes thank you i do i i do need to try
um
to keep on time um because i have
crap to do um after i wrap this up
have you ever seen russian doll i have
not uh i think liz saw it i haven't yet
though
uh
of course tom waits is great private
music you play captain hook and shrek
too yep fair point
uh
do you ever watch trashy tv like love
island etc not anymore
i used to
i used to like
years ago i watched jersey shore
and
when
vh1 had its whole
um
series of of love stuff so
uh flavor of love
rock of love
watch multiple seasons of
each of those
yeah
[Music]
fun fact there's a nebula that looks
like it's flipping the birds look it up
you gotta tell me what the nebula is
because i don't know how to i wouldn't
know what phrase to
google for that
i used to watch flavor of love yeah
uh
flavor flav
yeah
boy
um my kid's mother and i this is before
she was born
but
we used to buy
cheap champagne and drink the whole
bottle while watching new episodes of
flavor of love
oh boy
ah
anyways i think i am yeah we got about
two minutes left so
anybody got any last-minute queries or
whatever to throw my way get them in now
because i'm wrapping it up
thanks for the live first half of the
day was frustrating oh
well i hope it improves from here on out
um
always wondered why americans really
like dune
uh isn't it ironical
sorry if it's an offensive question here
the book reads very much like communist
propaganda i mean i
couldn't really
tell you too much about the appeal of it
other than like the imagination on
display it's a very imaginative work
um
but i i couldn't really answer that
question
i googled
nebula middle fingering images found it
okay fine i will look it up then
uh
[Music]
best worst moment in flavor of love was
when
something put on the floor i'd forgotten
about that
wow
good grief
final query what's your pin
pat's eyelashes
okay i'm wrapping it up i hope everybody
uh had fun
i hope that you all have a good rest of
the week
and um
i hope that you stay well
stay safe
and be kind
and more than anything i want you to
remember that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this
council is adjourned
my cavity